well a month ago as we said Democrats
are telling you that impeachment was an
urgent necessity it wasn't simply that
the president was a bad man they told
you that America's very national
security was at stake president Trump is
a clear and present danger to our free
and fair elections and our national
security the president is an ongoing
threat to our national security the
president betrayed our national security
and undermine the security of our
elections Donald Trump has been and
remains a threat to our national
security
he undermined America's national
security numerous crimes threatening the
national security severe threats to our
national security and democracy that we
cannot defend or dismiss he undermined
our national security and compromised
our national security so that he could
keep power he harmed America's national
security we must act without delay
without delay of course in the end the
delays were of the Democrats making it
in moreover in the end if peach would
seem to hurt the Democratic Party for
one thing it drove reasonable people out
of the party one example of this is
congressman jeff friend drew from south
jersey representated New Jersey in the
House of Representatives he joins us
tonight congressman you've been a
Democrat for an awful long time
this impeachment debacle and I think it
has been a debacle for the Democratic
Party convinced you to leave your to
leave your party it was part of it it
certainly was part of it I mean even the
most bizarre behavior that's occurring
right now I mean it was so important
that it be timely that it be done we had
to do it for the safety and good of the
country
that's voted no yeah no I didn't vote
for it because it was a weak impeachment
it wasn't in my opinion an accurate
impeachment and I don't think it should
have been done and it harmed the country
it split us apart it really hurt the
very essence of this nation I think in
many ways but they did it so we finally
did it and now the necessary paperwork
the articles impeachment have not been
transferred what did they say to you
when you didn't they knew I wasn't
because I was very upfront with folks
like you and everybody else that I could
talk to and really spoke to even some of
the individuals in the House of
Representatives
were more moderate on the Democrat side
were more conservative we do have the
blue dogs and everybody in the end
decided that they were going to go along
I was very surprised because we in
essence could have stopped it and that
and along with other things that I've
believed over the years about America
and the direction that America should
take whether we were talking he just had
a segment on about strong borders how we
need to have strong borders because what
is going on in Mexico etc I just think
we're going the wrong direction I think
the Democrats were going in the wrong
direction they are not the old blue dogs
that I remember of years ago and so I
really came to the point it was all it
all just came together it was like an
amazing situation where you know I heard
from the White House and at the same
time and by the way this was after I
already voted you know my way I didn't
vote for the MGP yes yeah there was no
there was never any question that gee if
you help us in vote a certain way with
impeachment then we'll help you if you
want to change parties never ever all it
was it all came together and sometimes
it happens in life and I feel more
comfortable as a Republican I've always
been more conservative and frankly I
feel like I've been liberated how
Democrats in your state and here in
Washington treated you most of them
there are some that haven't been nice or
don't talk to you there are some people
that wouldn't speak with you at all I've
also had some amazing reactions because
some people who even are independents or
undeclared or Democrats it wasn't only
the principle of you know where
Democrats are going and that's important
because something I disagree with it was
the idea that I was told and I was
speaking to you about this before by you
know I have eight counties and in one of
the counties one of the Chairman's said
to me you're voting for impeachment and
I've never had that before just somebody
spoke to me that way and I said what do
you mean he said you're voting for
impeachment where you're not gonna get
the line which is a big thing in New
Jersey and you're not gonna probably
even get to Iran in this county and I
said thank you very much and I just
walked away and I thought about it and
everything came together in my mind that
was a wrong suit yeah look about quid
pro quo I'm glad that threats didn't
work they didn't work
work and it was such a warm thing to do
and that's why some people who are not
even that political have been so amazing
and supportive because they said it took
guts what you did and you did the right
don't cave to the thugs that's the
lesson exactly
congressman thanks a lot for come on
Spain it was great to be on great
enjoyed it thank you